I used to want to save the world this
beautiful place
[Music]
but the closer you get the more you see
the great darkness within
[Music]
I learned this the hard way
a long long time ago
what is your mission to stop the war
well or the war to end all wars
weapons far deadlier than you can ever
imagine I welcome you Alice
[Music]
wherever you are you are in more danger
than you think cannot stand by while
innocent lives are lost
be careful Diana
who is this woman she's my secretary sir
she's a very good secretary
because there were sacred duty to defend
the world and it's what I'm going to do
[Music]
how can a woman possibly fight in this
fight we use our principles although I
am not opposed to engaging in a bitter
fisticuffs should the occasion arise
[Music]
your men yeah I mean
yeah
you have been my greatest love
be careful Diana I do not deserve you
[Music]
if you never met a man before but what
about your father I had no father I was
brought to life Isis collects need
[Music]
I cannot do this
what I do is not up to you
it's as a candy I'm at Steve Trevor's
secretary what is the secretary I go
where he tells me to go and I do what
you tells me to do I'm around from
that's called slavery I really like her
fantastic ladies a beauty I do Mike
more more and more less probably more
less